foreign
this could be your biggest box office
Opening Ever how does that sit with you
um the moment I start to read that
headline I'm like nope I can't see it I
can't see it I get that way I get a
little jinxy
get this the very first Black Adam
costume was padded and Dwayne ripped it
all out because it covered his
hard-earned physique as for his co-stars
Pierce Brosnan Aldous Hodge and Noah
centineo they told me getting into their
Caped Crusader costumes was a thrill
look at that suit like the four-year-old
the little like the inner child I mean
just exploded with happiness it was like
oh my God
it does Puff you up and then you realize
how heavy it is
[Music]
mine uh was about an extra like 35 40
pounds
if we're talking helmet Wars Pierce I
think I'm going with your helmet to top
all of them thank you I'm sorry thank
you I'm sorry it's pretty elegant it's
pretty slick it's very beautiful be
prepared
I had a hand in the design then we
looked at certain designs
that's awesome it was nice I'm not
peaceful the rock is the anti-hero Black
Adam who's accidentally released after 5
000 years in prison the movie hits
theaters October 21st and co-stars Viola
Davis Muhammad ammer and sex life Star
Sarah Shahi when you get the call that
you're going to be a part of this
project what is that moment like and
they were like you know you're gonna be
you know with Dwayne Johnson and I was
like which Dwayne Johnson and they were
like do you know another Dwayne Johnson
when you walk on set day one do you feel
like okay I need to tell him I went to
the gym yesterday I'm just so naturally
huge it was just hard for him to just be
around me all the time right right our
director John McLeod Sarah said there's
so much of you in Black Adam I said what
do you mean I don't kill people he goes
I don't mean that he he said but just
there is the DJ we get
and he goes but then also it's the DJ
that and he excuse my language and
there's a DJ we don't absolutely
absolutely right abs
[Music]